welcome to this video laying nibble
nibble nibble you know you never know
okay let's see we have the the NIMS Oh
Rubinstein reshef ski variation okay and
what setup is white coming up with with
d5 okay um when I'm put them actually
playing and playing this right with c6
attacking the center okay so are we
going to take everything off here I
guess we do the idea is to play for a
quick development night to be 3m yeah
let's let's go for that it's not just it
is it is an annoying move and I don't
really know what he's doing against it
every move looks problematic almost
maybe queen d 1 just just going back
the black is well developed that that's
one point of this is so it's set up okay
thus giving up the exchange directly not
sure that this was really necessary um
bishop is seven or no i don't i don't
think so let's just grab this and what
now a here okay go Bishop b2 and stuff
let's let's open up the queenside as
quickly as possible on giving him some
additional weaknesses down okay take it
Bishop e7 less maybe night h5 if you
address this is not very convenient do
we just want to check this on a four
maybe this is running into Bishop g5
that not a good idea yeah next move this
Bishop to be too
hmm what is the best way to actually
convert this maybe I should really do
that and get some play against the
before porn with Queen d6 stuff like
that just get them and get this involved
any cover of the porn is fairly
unnatural yeah like that quick in here
and see that we get Queens of the board
now he can play Queenie five but Bishop
g4 looks quite problematic yeah okay
let's let's play this end game okay
okay shoot t3 where are you going after
work the two I guess back then Bishop c3
and I'm going rook c8 no I want I want
the most active replacement possible
like this so Bishop c3 is not possible
okay it's really not not a big deal how
do we enter a ship Bishop to c5 I guess
yeah okay come on at first make sure
that nothing's ever going to happen down
and then Bishop c5 Bishop c5 immediately
I mean Bishop g7 maybe was possible it's
not not very likely a dangerous thing
but there's really no reason to allow it
Roxy wonders rook takes the form
white resigns um this was an opening and
opening problem 322 probably was already
slightly slightly problematic but of
course edger I just he can play Queenie
one just back and it's not that that
much of a problem I mean it does not
look very attractive but I don't really
see why this is so bad he can play this
next and then continue this is really
just an exchange I think I plated okay I
don't don't really think I allowed
allowed much rook a to even stronger but
okay it's an exchange in the end game so
nothing to be worried about much yeah
and my checks yeah there was an ok game
I didn't I don't think I allowed
something serious there I think he
reacted a bit too yeah this was a bit a
bit too early of those kind of
desperation with Queen d1 wasn't great
but at least you can play it without
being an exchange down for nothing ok
thanks for watching